running a village post office in north
wales meant everything to marjorie
williams but just two years after taking
it on her life fell apart when she was
wrongly accused of stealing from it in
2011.
convicted of fraud she was forced to pay
14 000 pounds and only avoided prison
after pleading guilty
i didn't want to go to jail
because i knew
my friend noah had been
and i didn't want to leave my daughter
and i thought at least
you know i'll be coming home hopefully
more than 700 post office staff were
prosecuted for theft and false
accounting between 2000 and 2014 in one
of the biggest miscarriages of justice
in british history
a faulty it system called horizon showed
up cash shortfalls that didn't exist but
that didn't stop many going to prison
damien owen was another giving evidence
on day two of an inquiry that'll look at
how much the post office knew of the
computer problems he was jailed for
eight months after being falsely accused
of stealing twenty 000 pounds
i lost an awful lot of weight i was in
there what
10 weeks
and in that 10 weeks i'd lost
four four and a half stone
it's clear that those who are giving
evidence here may never recover from
what happened to them they all still
suffer long-term physical or mental
health issues but they hope that by
reliving their ordeals they may finally
get some justice because to date no one
has been held accountable
damian says all he's received from the
post office is this one-sided apology
letter after his conviction was quashed
last year
i want to see convictions i want to see
perjury convictions i want to see people
from the top who have instigated this
and known
and pushed for convictions i want to see
them face the same kind of treatment
that they've dealt out to us
it's a scandal that's lasted more than
20 years it's hoped this will be one of
the final chapters iva bennett sky news